près de 200 étudiants de l'ue vs qu
attendait ce mardi après-midi les
directives pour commencer leur harlem
shakes cette danse conceptuel qui fait
le buzz sur internet et nous vient des
états unis
c'est une amie en fait on en fit qui
regardait une vidéo comme ça sur un
petit concours bon c'est pas très
sérieux mais voilà est quelqu'un de
notre staff bd a fortiori la repérer il
s'est dit bah pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
le faire donc c'est romain vergé qui
l'avait qui l'a repéré ça et pourquoi
pas le faire et pourquoi pas nous aussi
organisé à lui déçu parce qu'on sait que
les étudiants sont en demande de
d'événements comme ça sur la musique du
compositeur bauer un danseur est chargé
d'entraîner les personnes autour de lui
d'abord passible dans une chorégraphie
des gentils pendant que les étudiants
saint quentinois se place sous l'oeil de
nombreux curieux
le solitaire partage son état d'esprit
je sens bien un peu stressé mais ça va
être très marrant là je vais dégainer
une panse qui s'appelle la danse de
l'épaule une danse qui n'a ni queue ni
tête mais moi et bien action
oui
12 ans
g
colère